the switch-hitting catcher - right and
well hit that ball is out of here a
first inning two-run shot by Grondahl
[Applause]
the first pitch he saw from Scherzer
goes over the wall and right and they
are stunned here in DC on your deal here
and he has been arguably besides 1 for
16 guys career officers are coming into
tonight that one was worth every penny
sir she got behind the first hitter
Grissom he did not want to get behind
we're in golf he came to him and run
down was up for first two young
monogrammed all that this is Eric Thames
who launches to right-center field and
but Brewers have a three nothing lead
[Applause]
and people here are stunned that one was
off
[Applause]
to the captain what centerfield and that
ball is gone
20 Twitter
it's the Nationals on the board
[Applause]
in saltwater trying to get them out with
some sliders and way guys
absolutely
turning out the bat head to the ball
[Applause]
Diaz will the ball well hit to right
field laureano
that one is gone
[Applause]
[Applause]
yawn DDS opens the top of the first with
a solo home on the trend continues in
these long car games of early power up
however right in the wheelhouse looking
hard getting it and crushing down but I
am slowing the pace up a bit with a
runner on to start the inning and Garcia
gets a rocket out to center field that
ball is smoke cannon looks up and that
one is gone
the second homer of the game by the
Tampa Bay Rays and it's three nothing
for the visitors there's theater with
Miguel Cabrera take power taking it to
one fastball and just smashing it into
that 25-foot green wall up there at
centerfield an impressive majestic shot
by Garcia
it has after all been the year of the
homerun in Major League Baseball to kind
of add on to what we're talking about
same swing
[Applause]
yadi Diaz did it again
[Applause]
manney almost the same pitch same
location maybe a little bit further out
but here's the fastball away carbon copy
of the same pitch he hit his first
at-bat for a home run and Diaz is in way
go
[Applause]